the Nikki what up man are you serious I
have someone call me when you get out of
surgery all right you should drive out
there Ricky's been there for you guys
your whole lives the devil's in the
details my friend it work Atlantic City
here we come what we got Ricky's
cancer's back what does it have to be
cancer won't everybody get worried yeah
and that's going to take us right into
the World
[Music]
Series Ricky Nikki the best friend we
never
had my baby's going to be born 6 weeks
early I was born 6 weeks early oh I want
to know where the hell you guys were
tonight we called every hospital and
there was no record of a Ricky St Nikki
you know all we did was tell one lie
hundreds and hundreds of times over many
many years if the truth does come out my
marriage is over what if we hire an
actor to play
sikki Rock Hard Rod x-rated rock and
roll impersonated I do a whole act wall
the wall top to bottom jizz jams thanks
for coming out tonight ladies and
gentlemen so horny to be here this is a
really bad
idea oh Jesus I've been cold turkey in
the booze Ricky s Nicki in the program
remember oh R it's not what you think it
is it's just piss I'm a hyper every time
I want you to admit that Ricky Den Nikki
does not exist
[Applause]
hey this is Ted summer Hayes my boss Ted
nice to meet you dig in the suit in the
seedlings man the seedlings the hair
plugs they're new right this is my hair
we're going to lose our
[Music]
job epic night am I right guys throw it
and come back best I was really taken
with your friend sikki he's got brass
balls on him that guy that's why I hired
him that's awesome you just said what
did you say just say it one more time we
can't with him out of our sight not only
did I miss the birth of my son but I let
some porno Peter Frampton impersonator
snip his and we're done Nikki you are
unbelievable show's over rod it's Ricky
Ricky St Nikki is it real my job sucked
I had no friends but now I have all
those
things are you a fraud sir what you
talking
about we got to get rid of
him every time he tries to make a point
it's like he's smoking invisible dogs
dear God it's true to support now it
looks like I'm cupping the
[Music]
balls
I